burning  like my blood's in a pound on a stove  and it's heating me up  to the max so i'm running my legs just  as fast as i can  to the left to the right i'm a  frustrated man  now i'm flicking my tiptoes to kick up  the sand cause  i can't understand all this fire that's  raging inside me  seagulls in the sand can you hear my  prayer  i keep trying but i'm getting away  [Music]  leaping doing the splits from my heart  going higher and higher  my legs spread apart now i'm twirling  like a baby ballerina who's digging a  hole with the force of his feet  what's me climbing i'm gone up a palm  tree like a cat up a palm tree who's  decided to go  up a palm tree seal on the tire can you  hear my prayer  i keep trying but i'm getting  [Music]  am i in heaven or am i in hell  [Music]  [Applause]  again  [Music]  this couldn't be heaven i know  i'm in hell  [Music]  you